hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve pacific
atlantic water flow so this is another
problem from the blind 75 list and
that's why i'm doing it today the link
to this spreadsheet will be in the
description again
and so we will be able to fill in one
more graph problem today from that blind
75 list we're nearly done with that list
now at least most of the important
problems on this list i think there are
some binary questions that i haven't
really done and
i might not do these because i feel like
binary questions rarely come up in
interviews
but for this problem so the text is a
little small so let's focus
more on the picture so we're given a two
dimensional
grid of values and so each value
represents a
height so this has a height of 4 this
has a height of 5 etc etc
we are claiming that the top border
of our grid everything you know right
above our grid and everything to the
left of the grid is going to be
called the pacific ocean and everything
to the right of the grid and everything
below the grid
is going to be the atlantic ocean
so for any particular cell we want to
know
can this cell reach the pacific ocean
and can it reach the atlantic ocean
if it can then we are going to include
this position
in the result if it cannot reach the
atlantic and pacific ocean then we don't
include it in the result
so how do we know if this cell can reach
the pacific and atlantic ocean because
clearly there's a path
you know straight to it well there's one
condition
we want to know if water from this cell
can flow to the pacific end to the
atlantic and
water can only flow from the perspective
of a
cell to an adjacent cell that has
a value that is lower than the original
cell or
equal to the cell and it can only flow
in four directions
straight above to the left to the right
and below that's pretty straightforward
usually you can't go diagonally in these
types of graph problems
and so in this case for this five we see
that the above neighbor
three is less than five this is less
than five this is less than five and
this is less than five so
clearly five can go to all of its
neighbors
now let's take a look at the three okay
three has a neighbor one
one is less than three so it can
definitely flow in that direction and
now
see this one is bordering the atlantic
ocean so clearly
that means five is able to reach the
atlantic ocean
now let's look left it can reach four
and four can definitely reach two
because two
is less than or equal to four so from
this perspective we can also now reach
the pacific ocean
so water from this position can flow to
the pacific
and it can flow to the atlantic so this
position is going to be included in
our result so a brute force and naive
way to solve this problem is to
simply go to every single position
do some kind of graph traversal dfs or
bfs would probably work
and doing that search check from a cell
can we reach the top
and left border and can we reach the
right
and bottom border and if we can then
we're going to add this cell
to the solution set if we can't then we
don't add it right
so if we're doing a dfs or bfs on every
single position
starting at every single position in the
grid we're gonna get a time complexity
of basically the size of the grid let's
say that's that's
n times m which is you know the
dimensions of the grid
and if we do that from every single
starting point we're gonna get
n by m squared as the big o
time complexity and you might think well
since
we're doing this recursively we're
probably doing a lot of repeated work
right so for example if i'm starting at
right doing a dfs from here i'm gonna go
to its neighbors and then do dfs from
here
here here and here and maybe
you know by doing that i can cut out the
repeated work right
and so i won't and so we won't have to
you know restart a dfs for every single
position
in the entire grid and you might think
that that will work
but i'm pretty sure it doesn't i'm not
going to go through
the details of why and somebody in the
comments can correct me if i'm wrong
maybe there is a clever way to get that
to work
but i i tried to do it myself and i was
not able to so i don't know if it's
actually possible
to do it that way there's a different
clever way to solve this problem
how about rather than us going through
every single cell
and checking if this cell can reach
pacific and reach atlantic how about
we go for start from the pacific ocean
right and let's find every
cell that borders the pacific ocean
clearly
everything in the first row borders the
pacific ocean right that means
everything in this cell can reach the
pacific ocean
and everything in the left column can
also
reach the pacific ocean and starting
from each of these nodes
what we're going to do is now find what
are all the
other nodes that can also reach the
pacific ocean right so
at the end we would have you know some
kind of set maybe you know it looks
something like this right
or whatever and then we know okay these
are all all the ones in purple
can reach the pacific ocean and
similarly
we would also do that with the atlantic
ocean we know everything
here on the right side can reach the
atlantic ocean
everything at the bottom can reach the
atlantic ocean similarly we do some kind
of dr
graf traversal starting from each of
these positions
right and see okay what what nodes can
reach the
pacific ocean as well and at the end we
would want to go through every single
position in the grid and we'd want to
find
positions like this one that can reach
the atlantic
and pacific ocean that we marked as
being able to reach the atlantic
and pacific and then from these ones
that can reach both we would add them to
our result and then return the results
so that's kind of
the general algorithm of how we're going
to do things the reason this is more
efficient
this is going to be big o n times m
we're not going to be revisiting nodes
mult
you know several times we're not going
to be re-running a graph traversal
what we're going to be doing is starting
at each of these nodes right doing a
depth first search right so
for example let's say we started at this
one right we'd do a depth first search
and then see all the other nodes that
can reach the pacific ocean right
you know let's say we marked these and
these right and then maybe we do the
same thing starting at this one
right and we'd you know go over here
maybe and then go over here and then
we'd come back here if we ever got to a
cell that we
revisited we would not want to continue
our debt for search from
a repeated cell right so we we just
wouldn't do that
so that's the main idea of this
algorithm but there's one last point i
want to make before i start going
through the code
and that is remember how if we're
starting at a cell like this one
water can flow from this cell to a cell
that has a smaller
value right like a cell a small cell
like three for example and then it can
flow down to a smaller cell like one and
then it can reach the ocean right
so if we are going starting from a cell
and reaching the ocean
we are allowed to go at equal heights so
one can reach one
or we can go in decreasing heights like
these ones
but if we're going in the opposite
direction if we're starting
at the atlantic ocean and going to a
cell like 1
going to a cell like 3 and going to a
cell like 5 then we're
going to have to do the opposite we can
go to cells of
equal heights or cells of increasing
heights right
you kind of see why that's the case
because what we're saying is
water is allowed to flow from five to
three to
one so therefore water from the ocean is
allowed to go
from one to three to five because that
does mean that
five can reach the ocean so with that
being said
the first thing i'm gonna do is go
through
the first row which is gonna be pacific
ocean
values and then i'm gonna and from there
i'm gonna run depth first search to see
all the other nodes
that can reach the pacific ocean and i'm
gonna do the same thing at the
bottom row seeing which nodes can reach
the atlantic ocean
and i'm gonna be maintaining those in a
set let's call it a visit set it's going
to be a hash set so that
we don't end up adding duplicates to it
so now getting into the code so the
first thing i like to do with these
problems is just get the dimensions of
the grid so we're guaranteed that this
grid is not going to be empty so we
don't have to
you know worry about that so let's get
the length of heights which is going to
give us the number of rows
and then get the number of columns as
well
and so i'm going to be having two hash
sets pacific and atlantic
maintaining all the positions that can
reach the pacific and atlantic oceans
respectively
and then what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
go through every single position
in the first row so i'm gonna go through
every single column
in the first row right and what's going
to be every single position in the first
row from here it's going to be
0 0 right in the first row is 0 and
column is going to be the column
position and so what i want to do
on this position is run a dfs right so
i'm going to run a dfs on this position
right
and so i'm going to pass in a visit set
to this dfs function
since this is the first row the first
row means it's the pacific ocean right
it's not the atlantic it's the pacific
so that's what i'm going to pass in as
the visit set
the pacific ocean so i want to visit
this position and i want to see all the
other positions it can reach
now we know that water from the ocean
to other cells can only go at equal
values or
greater values right remember we
reversed the thinking since we're going
from the ocean to the cells we're going
to have to do the opposite
so we can go to greater cells so i want
to always pass in a previous height
variable to this so if we're going to
visit a cell i want to make sure that
you know we're allowed to visit that
cell so i'm going to pass in a previous
height so
since there is no previous height for
this position i can just give it a
default value and i'll just give it the
same height as this position because
that's going to be allowed remember
we're always allowed
to visit heights of the exact same
height
as the previous position and so while
we're at this
right we're going through every position
in the first row
why not go through every single position
in the last row
which tells us the atlantic ocean right
so what's the last row it's going to be
the number of rows
minus one and going through every column
in that rows and
so instead of passing in pacific let's
pass an atlantic
because the bottom row refers to the
atlantic ocean and similarly we'll pass
in the height
of this position as the previous height
so we're calling this dfs function so
let's might as well define it up above
here now
the first two parameters are going to be
the row and column and the next is going
to be the visit set now
since we're reusing this function for
both atlantic and pacific we'll just
give it a generic name like visit we
could be passing in either of these two
sets and the last parameter is the
previous
height so if this position has already
been visited meaning
if row column is in
visit then we're going to return we're
not going to continue this function or
if it's out of bounds we're also not
going to return right because remember
we're already going
from the ocean from let's say the
pacific ocean and trying to visit
all the cells that we can because that's
going to tell us
all the cells that can reach the pacific
ocean so we're not even trying to reach
the ocean right now
we're going from the ocean to all the
cells so if we go out of bounds then
we're going to have to return so
if let's say r is less than 0 or
c is less than zero or if r is
equal to the number of rows that means
we've gone too large
or if c is equal to the number of
columns that also means we've gone too
large
and the last case where we would want to
return is if
the height of this position row column
is less than the previous height
because remember we're only allowed to
go to heights of greater height or equal
so if the height was too small
then we would want to return if we're
not returning that means we're finding a
new cell so let's go ahead and add it to
visit we're visiting this new cell row
column
and then on all four of its neighbors we
also want to run dfs
on all four of those neighbors and we
could do that with a loop but i'm lazy
so i don't want to write that out i'm
just going to
copy and paste this four times so so row
column
passing in visit and passing in the
previous height which is just going to
be
heights at this position row column
let's copy and paste this four times and
so
we're gonna go through all four of its
neighbors so row plus one
is one neighbor row minus one is a
neighbor column plus one
is another neighbor and column minus one
is another neighbor
and that's going to be the entire dfs
function for us
it's going to be marking all nodes that
can visit
that can reach the pacific ocean or the
atlantic ocean depending on what we pass
in
and so right now we're doing that for
the first row and the last row
but we also know the first column is
going is going to be
the pacific ocean and the last column is
going to be the atlantic ocean so let's
do that so for every
row in range of rows
we want to get every position at the
left
most column and call dfs on it so
for row we're just going to pass in the
current row we're going to go through
every single row and for column we're
going to pass in zero
right we know that the first column is
zero and if
and the first column can reach the
pacific ocean so that's what we're going
to pass in and for heights
we're just going to give it the default
value of this position
and similarly let's do the same thing
for the last row
let's do the same thing for the last
column so for
columns instead of zero let's do columns
minus one
and instead of pacific let's pass in the
atlantic ocean because that's
what the rightmost column refers to and
heights is going to be the same default
value
and so we don't have to rewrite the dfs
function right because we already wrote
it up above here we're reusing that
function
so once these two loops have executed we
will have marked
every single position that can reach the
pacific ocean
in here and we'll have done the same
with the atlantic ocean so
now after that let's just go through
every single position in the grid
brute forcing it so every single
position every single row every single
column
and for every single position we want to
know if
this position row column is in
the pacific ocean and if row column
is in the atlantic ocean then what we
want to do
is let's first declare a result list
if this position was in both atlantic
and pacific we want to go ahead and add
it to
our result and we want to add it as a
let's say as a sub list and so once
we've done that then we have definitely
found out every single
position that can reach both atlantic
and pacific ocean and then we can go
ahead and return that result
okay i had a pretty stupid bug so sorry
about that so when we're passing in
uh we're you know we're finding the
position of heights so
you know we have column because that's
what we're at for row we should have
zero because that's the position that
we're starting at so sorry about that
let's change this to a zero and
similarly down here
i actually think we have this right so
rows minus one because that matches over
here but down here
we have row and column zero so we want
to change column to zero over here
and over here we do have row so that
matches but columns minus 1
is the column value that we want to pass
in so with those changes you can see
that this solution does work and it is
about as efficient as you can get for
this problem
so i hope that this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe
it supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching